[Music]
all right hello and welcome everyone to
active lab live stream number 39.0
it's february 25th 2022
welcome to the active lab we are a
participatory online lab that is
communicating learning and practicing
applied active inference you can find us
at the links here on the slide
this is a recorded in an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so we can improve our work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following good
video etiquette for live streams
if you want to learn more about
coms which is the organizational unit
that puts on all these live streams and
many other products or any of the other
activities in the active lab go to
activeinference.org
all right well
today in active stream number 39.0 the
goal is to learn and discuss
this really awesome paper called
morphogenesis as bayesian inference
a variational approach to pattern
formation and control in complex
biological systems it's by franz
koochling carl firsten georgiegiv and
michael levin from 2020
and just like all the dot zero videos
and indeed all our videos it's just an
introduction to some of these ideas it's
not a review
or a final word
that being said we're going to go over
the aims claims abstract roadmap keyword
etc of the paper and then
with a focus on the first parts of the
paper and less so on the formalism and
more on the big ideas we're going to go
over the paper and the figures
and that will put us in a good position
cognitively or morphologically we might
even say for
the discussions in the coming weeks 39.1
and 39.2
when we'll get to unpack this so if you
would like to it'd be awesome to have
you participate live or if it's past
39.2 you can still ask questions
all right we'll start with introductions
and warm-ups
we can each
say hi and maybe one thing that was
exciting or interesting about the paper
which all reserved for after you but i'm
daniel i'm a researcher in california
and dean thanks a ton for joining
uh thanks natalie i'm dean i'm here in
calgary
and
what really got me excited about this
was
uh the idea that they talk a little bit
later close to the end we may not even
talk about it today is
the uh role that epigenetics might play
in terms of how cells behave and
and what sorts of things we might be
able to turn turn in terms of
simply um what we see in biological form
into some sort of static
statistical prediction device so i'm
really excited about that awesome
yeah
it's a
complex paper about complex systems so
we'll see what we can get done today but
i'm really excited to bring
active inference into
this domain at least as far as our
discussions go into the morphological
and the morphogenetic areas
and it's just bringing like another
lens another way that we can apply
active inference as a filter
another set of phenomena that we're
bringing into
this active inference
realm
so we'll just go right into the big
question so i'll read this and then feel
free to give a thought
the big question or at least one way to
put one of the questions is how can we
find an integrative path between math
and morphogenesis morphogenesis means
form
like physical form morpho and genesis
meaning how it arises so how does
physical form arise and how is that
related to math
and to kind of unpack that here's some
quotes
the molecular mechanisms
which are like signaling pathways of all
different kinds
underlying development and regeneration
in biological organisms
have undergone a tremendous amount of
knowledge gain in the last several years
due to genomics and biotechnology
advances
so that's kind of the
one side with the biological and then
from the mathematical and the formal the
emerging field of the free energy
principle in pattern formation
not always morphogenetic patterns but
can be cognitive patterns rhythmic
patterns
provides an essential quantitative
formalism for understanding cellular
decision making in the context of
embryogenesis regeneration and cancer
suppression
so if that's the if
then
how might the mathematical formalism
reveal new understandings about
developmental change in evolution
and for designing new interventions in
regenerative medicine settings so what
do you think about that
well i just love anytime that two things
that seem disparate or distant are are
brought together because i think all
sorts of good things can happen and i'm
going to do a little shout out that's
kind of what i would like to
see if we can organize in august with a
couple of other papers that don't start
out necessarily appearing to be
close or proximal but by bringing
together all kinds of interesting things
can happen
awesome
okay
to the main aims and claims of the paper
so the paper is in physics of life
reviews 2020 and we already mentioned
the title and the authors
just to select a few aims that the
authors represent and then a couple of
key claims that are relevant for the
paper
so as far as aims go one of their aims
is to introduce an overarching concept
that can predict the emergence of form
and the robust maintenance of complex
anatomy
another aim is to
derive the mathematics behind bayesian
inference and use simulations to show
simulations that are consistent and
within the bayesian framework to show
that the formalism can reproduce
experimental top-down manipulations of
complex morphogenesis
and then just a few of their claims more
of which we'll be unpacking in the
coming minutes
classic
i.e dynamical systems and analytical
mechanics
approaches such as last at least action
principles
are difficult to use when characterizing
open far from equilibrium systems that
predominate in biology so that's kind of
a big challenge that's come up again and
again which is we might have really
great equations for a pendulum maybe
even a pendulum with friction but how
about an active pendulum that's doing
strategy and trying to run away from you
a bit harder to put those same equations
on
the bayesian inference framework treats
cells as
information processing agents
where the driving force behind
morphogenesis is the maximization of a
cell's model evidence
which is to say its reduction of
uncertainty relative to a generative
model which is what we're going to be
unpacking
and
we had previously read this
about how they're applying free energy
principle to morphogenesis
when it goes well
like during embryogenesis
and results in a zygote becoming like an
adult life form as well as all of the
ways that it's maintained during that
stationarity of healthy life and
including cases where it might be
relevant to even think about making
interventions like medical settings
so those are a few of the aims and
claims
anything to add on it
yeah just real quick it's really
interesting that they said top down and
then we're going to see some
slides where there's a top top
and
a down down so
stick around
because there's actually going to be
something kind of interesting happening
here
okay
how about you read the first half of the
um the top half of this abstract slide
yeah sure recent advances in molecular
biology such as gene editing bioelectric
recording and manipulation and live cell
microsc
microscopy
using fluorescent reporters especially
with the advent of light controlled
protein activation through optogenetics
have provided the tools to measure and
manipulate molecular signaling pathways
with unprecedented spatial temporal
precision this has produced
ever-increasing detail about the
molecular mechanisms underlying
development and regeneration bought in
biological organisms however
an overarching concept
that can predict the emergence
of form and the robust maintenance of
complex anatomy is largely missing in
the field
classic
i.e dynamic systems and analytical
mechanics approaches such
at least action as least action
principles are difficult to use when
characterizing open
far from equilibrium systems that
predominate in biology similar issues
arise in neuroscience when trying to
understand neuronal dynamics from first
principles so they're basically covering
their
bases here by making sure that we
understand this is open
system
yes
increases in tools
in biological systems like genomics
microscopy optogenetics are helping us
reduce our uncertainty about the what
but without
a bit more information about the how and
the why etc that's the overarching
concept that's largely missing
so we can grind up the cells and
sequence the genome we can extract the
rna and we can even tell what the ratio
of different rna molecules is but it
turns out that that type of information
alone
doesn't help us understand why two
related species or the same species in
two different contexts or the same
genome in two different tissues or the
same tissue in two different
environments has such different
morphology
okay
and then the second half in this
neurobiology setting a variational free
energy principle has emerged based upon
a formulation of self-organization in
terms of active bayesian inference
the free energy principle has recently
been applied to biological
self-organization beyond the
neurosciences
for biological processes that underwrite
development or regeneration
the bayesian inference framework treats
cells as information processing agents
where the driving force behind
morphogenesis is the maximization of a
cell's model evidence
this is realized by the appropriate
expression of receptors and other
signals that correspond to the cell's
internal ie generative
model of what type of receptors and
other signals it should express
the emerging field of the free energy
principle in pattern formation provides
an essential quantitative formalism for
understanding cellular decision making
in the context of embryogenesis
regeneration and cancer suppression
okay and then if you read the first
um two parts here on the second slide
yeah no problem in this paper we derive
the mathematics behind
bayesian inference as understood in this
framework and use simulations to show
that formalism can reproduce
interesting experimental top-down
manipulations of complex morphogenesis
first we illustrate the first principle
approach to morphogenesis through
simulated alterations of anterior
posterior
axial polarity
the induction of two heads or two tails
ah spoiler alert as a planarian
regeneration
don't you hate it when the abstract
spoils the paper
then we consider aberrant signaling and
functional behavior of a single cell
within a cellular ensemble as a first
step in carcinogenesis the formation of
cancer
as false beliefs about what a cell
should sense and do
inference perception action inference
we further show that simple
modifications of the inference process
can cause
and rescue
mispatterning of developmental and
regenerative events without changing the
implicit generative model of a cell as
specified for example
by its dna
this formalism offers a new roadmap
for understanding developmental change
in evolution and for designing new
interventions in regenerative medicine
settings
speaking of the new roadmap
let's look at the roadmap
kind of cool that they actually
say that it is
providing a road map so we've talked
about guides
we've talked about road maps where do
you see all of that before we look at
the section titles
well
a guide i think
basically gives
sort of gives you um
the parameters i think a roadmap is a
lot more specific in terms of the
sequencing but that's just my
interpretation of it i think
other people can interpret roadmap
roadmap differently in terms of sort of
the relational aspect of how the
different parts come together and we've
talked about that in other live streams
but
i don't want to get bogged down in this
part right now because
i think we got a lot of stuff to cover
here
cool yeah so the paper begins with an
introduction to bayesian inference
section 2 is mathematical foundations
that are building on bayesian inference
so going from kind of bayes theorem to
several dynamical systems
representations some of which we've
discussed before others which will push
it into a little bit of a new area
then
the key
contribution and the focus of the paper
is modeling morphogenesis
and so instead of just presenting bays
and then variational bays and then free
energy minimization on
a bacterium like we saw axle constant do
in live stream number 34
we're going to take that
momentum
and move it towards an application of
modeling in morphogenesis
and that's where we'll talk about like
what model they construct and how it
relates to some of the formalisms that
were brought up earlier
and then
there's a discussion and conclusion
section which we won't go too much into
today in the dot zero but it's going to
be awesome to go into it in the dot one
and dot two
because there's a ton of awesome
content and material
all right
so here's the keywords that were listed
and we won't go into um
[Music]
most of them
just to say that they're going to come
up in this discussion we have free
energy principle bayesian inference
morphogenesis and developmental biology
regeneration
kind of got some mathematical stuff
we've seen before
we have a triad
of
developmental biology which broadly
understood includes embryogenesis as
well as
aging and cancer and all these other
developmental things that happened
during biology and top-down muddling and
maybe we'll see what that means coming
up
okay well to get right into it
section one is an introduction to
bayesian inference
so
here's a nice picture by sasha
and here are the opening lines of the
paper
they wrote and then feel free to give a
thought
evolutionary change results from
mutations in dna and selection acting on
functional bodies
thus it is essential to understand how
the hardware encoded by the genome
enables the behavioral plasticity of
cells that can cooperate to build and
repair complex anatomies
indeed most problems of biomedicine
repair of birth defects regeneration of
traumatic injury tumor reprogramming etc
could be addressed if prediction and
control could be gained over the
processes by which cells implement
dynamic pattern homeostasis
the fundamental knowledge gap and
opportunity of the next decades in the
biosciences
is to complement bottom-up molecular
understanding of mechanisms
with a top-down computational theory of
cellular decision making and info taxes
movements towards information
so
dean what do you think
what should we study and why and how is
this related to active and fep
okay well my background in genetics is
is near zero but what i did come away
from with that last bullet in particular
was
uh some one of the things that i
beat like a dead animal which is that
you need a minimum of two and i think
that the
the bottom up sort of building blocks
aspect of it with the top down how do we
get a better grip on what the signals
are that are passing between
all of those bricks um was really
interesting and so
carrying on through
i i kind of wanted to open that up and
see what that um that marriage looked
like
awesome
so speaking as someone who started in
the science journey with genetics pretty
much
it always was so interesting how
genetics would frame itself as if the
bottom-up information flow could just
simply replace theory we'll sequence so
many genomes we won't need to speculate
about evolution or we'll have your
genome so we won't even need to ask
about what medicine is best
and that's kind of this bottom-up
molecular understanding which is vital
it's essential it's important it's
changing a lot
but it's this bottom-up
sub-unit description
the what and the where of the subunits
and how they touch and all of that
and that is always met implicitly and
increasingly explicitly with a top-down
theory of cellular decision-making and
infotaxes and so we're always kind of
meeting in the middle with empirical wet
lab biology revealing these mechanisms
and these findings
and we're meeting that as researchers
doing model-based science with what are
being called here top-down modeling
top-down computational theories
okay that's just how they open up and
also set a challenge for the coming
decades
it's their expectation of the next few
then they provide a math roadmap
which is an awesome paragraph
so they write we lay out the
mathematical foundations of a type of
bayesian modeling
that they're going to use to simulate
pattern formation
so red bayesian modeling
orange we start by identifying a
lyapunov function
that can be used to analyze and solve
any dynamic system using the fundamental
theorem of vector calculus i.e the
helmholtz decomposition
so we're using bayesian modeling and
layering in what we'll talk about soon
the leopard function
green we use it to characterize the
generalized flow of systemic states
states of the whole system in terms of
conversions to a non-equilibrium steady
state a ness
next layer blue
we then introduce the notion of a markov
blanket that separates the external and
internal states of the system
and finally purple
we can then replace the leopard function
with a variational free energy function
to solve for the evolution of internal
and active states
that's
of the particle
and thereby characterize
self-organization in far from
equilibrium systems that can be
partitioned into a cell
and an external milieu
that's the math that they go through
that's the math rainbow then
sections after that
apply this formalism to illustrate
morphogenesis and neoplasia which is the
growth of new forms neoplasia
using simulations
and what's so cool is this
trajectory
from 400 to 700 nanometers
from the bays
through the vector calculus and flow
states
to the finding or the figuring out of a
markov blanket
and then
the usage of the markov partitioning
legitimated
by the orange and the green steps
to find a heuristic way to go about
solving
what was
needing to be addressed right in the
beginning
we've seen some variants of this
trajectory multiple times
and then
in this paper they studied morphogenesis
and so then they model morphogenesis but
say for a couple of words
a different paper could have said we do
the base thing the lyapunov thing the
helmholtz
the nest the markov and then we're back
to doing far from equilibrium
strategy in
online teams
and then we applied it to online teams
and so
let's keep in mind like the paper can be
long there are a lot of equations but
where is this broader trajectory that's
helping us fine-tune our regime of
attention and update our generative
model about what we are doing here and
how it's different than other approaches
and then where is the part that's
actually studying morphogenesis
just things to keep in mind okay
anything to add on this
well you
correct me if i'm wrong on this but i
think what we're doing is
essentially
taking
as you said we can we can look at a
variety of things we can look at
the physical nature of ants we can look
at cells we can look at
online teams
whatever we're looking at what they
basically said is
there is a there is a parallel
way of looking at the formalisms
that exist in those contexts with that
with that
type of content
that's essentially what this said to me
there's a way of bumping it up into that
sort of statistical mathematical realm
and now we're going to walk you through
what that is
great
okay so into
the bay
the bay's area where i grew up
so
sitting by the dock of the base all
right oh i thought so i'm gonna say
where the water well where the
watermelons grow carry on
base theorem rests on three basic axioms
of probability theory and is used to
relate
the conditional probability of an
unobservable event a okay so the
vertical bar means conditioned upon or
given
and so what we really want to know is
like the probability of something that
we cannot observe
conditioned on what we did observe be
so you're never observing the lightning
strike you're observing photons on your
receptor and then you want to know about
whether there was lightning in that
cloud over a few miles away so we want
to know the conditional probability of
an unobservable event a that's this left
hand side
we want to relate that to
an observable quantity b
that's what the data are
and that's going to be calculated using
the bayes theorem as
the probability of the data
given
the unobservable state which is called a
prior so that's like
had to do with cats and meowing or in a
previous example or it has to do with
like
if there were lightning yes or no what
would be the likelihood of me observing
photons
multiplied by the probability of those
unobservable states happening which is
of course a prior about them but it
could be
set with empirical data
divided by how likely the data are which
is called p of b the marginal likelihood
or evidence
okay so p of a given b is called the
posterior because it's like after
you've done your inference you want the
correct posterior which is like updated
beliefs about how likely the thing that
you care about a is given what has come
in
priors are like prior to this round of
inference
what are your beliefs about how likely a
is
and then
the evidence coming in is be
okay
and the likelihood is how likely the
data are
under the prior distribution
so that's bayes theorem and we've talked
about it multiple times and i'm sure
there's other awesome videos and courses
that can explain it even better
how are they using it here
to describe the dynamics of an ensemble
of information processing agent like
cells
as a process of bayesian belief updating
we need to relate the stochastic
differential equations governing
newtonian motion
and biochemical activity to the
probabilistic quantities above
long sentence but
it's kind of saying we need to connect
these variables which are informational
they're probabilistic they're
statistical to
movement in space
movement in a newtonian coordinate
system
because we need these variables to
measure spatial movement so we can study
morphogenesis this is fairly
straightforward to do if we
associate biophysical states with the
parameters of a probability density
and ensure their dynamics perform a
gradient flow on a quantity called
variational free energy
variational free energy is a quantity in
bayesian statistics that
when minimized
ensures the parameterized density
converges to the posterior belief as we
will see below
so yes this is our first slide on bayes
theorem and we did just kind of go from
the total
description of the variables and what is
bayes theorem out of first pass to this
introduction of the variational free
energy so
it can be accordioned out and unpacked a
lot more but
what variational free energy is doing
is helping us tractably
converge to
the appropriate posterior
belief and that's its role here
okay
anything to add on this one dean
well i'll ask you a question so if you
were to talk to this to somebody for the
first time
not people who probably listened to
other of our live streams
would you say that it would be
um dangerous to say that we're taking
something that's kind of ratio based
and now
using that to try to build a model of
what our predictions
are going to
be based on
is that
is that fair to say
i believe so
it's like
one way to approach that
i hope this would be accessible the
ratio-based part is on the right-hand
side
and um one could say depending on like
how much data you're getting and what
you're trying to estimate it could be
very hard to go from
observations to inference on hidden
states
pretty fair conclusion
so
what we could do
would be construct a smooth
approximatable model
so that when we slide to the bottom of
our model just like the ball sliding
down the hill
we would actually be doing the same
thing as
fitting this effectively
so instead of like number crunching and
putting everything into this equation
and running the calculation
we're going to construct
a bowl
which is the variational free energy
that we can do gradient descent on that
is going to converge to a really good
solution
do we construct it or do they do they
kind of tell us that
we should assume it if we want to make
it tractable
assume the bowl
when we pick up this instrument
we're making variational free energy
bowls
yeah okay good
and we've seen this before
um
in
live streams
32 and 34
we did some variants on moving from
bayes theorem and exact base
to
variational inference which uses this
variational free energy value
so those are a few times that we've seen
this discussed before
in neuroscience the minimization of
variational free energy
is referred to as
active inference
we will see that the basic when the
basic condition for an inference type
description of a system
namely the existence of a markov blanket
separating external and internal states
is satisfied
agents such as biological cells form
into organized conglomerations based on
their generative model of how their
blanket states influence
and are influenced by
external states in the external milieu
so the connection between bayes theorem
and markov blankets is the unobservables
are external states
the observables are blanket states
it's a pretty fair model
whether it also provides like strong
guarantees on optimal perception or
optional action that's another
discussion but
at the very least it's a fair framing
that external states are unobserved if
you could observe them they'd be
observables then they'd be more like b
than a
so we're talking about a situation where
we have some a's and we have some b's
and we're going to think about that in
terms of a blanket formalism
and
the dynamics of a system with a markov
blanket that self-organizes to
non-equilibrium steady states can be
described as a gradient flow on this
computable variational free energy bound
so we can set up the blanket and it
turns out that we don't have to do the
ratio number crunch we can do
the bowl gliding down
that's the beginning part on just bays
that takes us from bayes theorem to
introducing variational free energy and
doing gradient descent on variational
free energy
so that one can effectively essentially
perform bayesian inference
cool
perfect okay section two mathematical
foundations
all right
so section 2.1 stability and convergence
in coupled dynamical systems and
subsection 1 the helmholtz decomposition
so they write the helmholtz
decomposition states that any
sufficiently smooth
i.e possessing continuous derivatives
vector field f
can be decomposed into an irrotational
curl free
so kind of
straight up and down putting the ruler
and finding the slope of a hill
and
a solenoidal divergence-free vector
field the divergence free solenoidal is
like putting the ruler
at ground level
and then being able to make an iso
contour around a hill
because an irrotational vector field has
only a scalar potential
and the solenoidal vector field has only
a vector potential we can express the
vector field as
insert formalism two
and just so people know the upside down
triangle is called del or nabla which
means harp due to the shape
so del
phi
is
the irrotational
vector field
del a is the solenoidal field
we talked about this mostly in
um
number 26 and 32
where we talked about the partition or
the decomposition
into a solenoidal and a gradient
as well as this housekeeping term which
was
everyone's favorite housekeeping term so
we're not um
having a housekeeping term here
but we're keeping in mind that it's not
implausible that
it's
still there
it's just that there was a whole paper
coming out after
this morphogenesis paper
that
talked about the housekeeping etc so
again it wouldn't be surprising if a
future morphogenesis paper or project
did have this housekeeping term but um
32 was actually a later paper so that
might be a more advanced placed um or
updated place to check out
how the partition i'm sorry the um
helmholtz decomposition works
and here was a image from
just showing how you could have like a
kind of
um
hill
and in physics you could have hill
climbing and trying to get to the top
or
sometimes it's easier to think about
that as like the flip
and the ball rolling to the bottom of
the hill so whether it's the optimistic
biologists talking about going up to the
fitness peak or whether it's the
pessimistic physicists talking about
going to the bottom of the energy well
it's the same idea
that there's a particle on a landscape
and there's been a ton of work on
passive particles that's not to say
immobile particles but particles that
roll and get trapped and then once
they're trapped they stay or they jiggle
stochastically
we're studying active particles and so
that's where action selection comes into
play landscapes of energy with balls
rolling down them but they're kind of
like jumping beans where they also have
a few tricks that they can play
okay anything to add here
just just a reminder to people that
that's a density that we're looking at
not not a
not a
not a vacuum it's a
i know most people when they hear like
if i was to talk to younger people and
they started imagining a ball rolling
down a hill they would they wouldn't
necessarily
confirm that it's an
actual density that we're looking at so
just reinforce that
yeah like the bottom right here it's
kind of like you're looking down at an
ink drop
and that's where it's densest is where
it's darkest and then that is like a
landscape where where it's darkest is
highest
right
okay
section two one two the openiv functions
okay so the opposite functions have been
used extensively in dynamical systems
theory and engineering
to characterize the stability of fixed
points of a dynamical system
the operative functions are generally
defined for smooth systems through the
following conditions
so l is going to be the leopard if
function
and x is going to be a point
so
a fixed point is going to be x star
and a non-fixed point is going to be
just regular x so x star the special
points where if you are there you're
perfectly balanced
so
this is saying that
at fixed points
the lyapunov function
evaluates as zero
and it's not zero
if it's not a fixed point
and
the leaping function
change in l with respect to time
it's below zero
for all x
equation three a requires the leopard
function to be minimal for fixed points
x star representing local minima
and b denotes conversions to these fixed
points over time so what does it mean to
have a leopard value of 0
above zero or below zero so if you're at
zero just like it said with the fixed
points that means that it's not moving
at all
a leopard if exponent below zero means
that things are converging towards
the openiv
bigger than zero means diverging away
specifically what it means is two points
that are really really close to each
other
do they stay exactly the same distance
away that's zero
a negatively operative means that two
points close to each other will converge
so that's a convergence attractor
and then positively open of exponents
the opposite values
mean that two points that are placed
very close to each other will diverge
away from each other
i hope i have not oversimplified or made
unforced errors about the opponent
functions because it's obviously a
really technical area
and they write following 16 we can
generalize this local leopard function
of stability
so zero equal fixed point positive
equals divergence negative equals
convergence to a globally open a
function that plays the role of a
potential function of any dynamical
system
and we won't go into it but it is the
citation to this ryoshi
paper from 2013
and they do some pretty interesting math
so if somebody's more familiar with this
it would be awesome to hear about
but what this is doing is it's taking
this same dynamical systems perspective
that we've been thinking about about
things changing through time and then
overlaying
on that landscape
a stability landscape and so if we think
about like this hill on the top right
again hopefully not
being
wrong or misleading here
at the very top of the hill
it's like a fixed point it's an unstable
fixed point but if one were perfectly
balanced there we could just say
um it could get knocked off by
stochastic things which we'll come back
later but it's perfectly balanced it's
like a fixed point
two points that were very close to each
other
on a hill
two balls placed right next to each
other would start to diverge as they
rolled down the hill
so that would be like a slight
divergence
and so that is what the lyapunov
function as potential function is
allowing it's allowing us to take the
landscape of ball rolling where gravity
is the potential function
the higher up the more potential you
have and then it rolls down because the
dissipation of potential energy
and they're going to
um
show that any dynamics with lyapunov
function so any smooth differentiable
etc landscape has a corresponding
physical realization a friction force a
lorentz force and a potential function
so we can think about this leopard
function being related to potential
functions like something that draws the
system back
that's where the negative lyapunov comes
into play okay dean
just a quick thing daniel
when we were setting up the slides
between those two bullets um they they
talked about something called a saddle
point did you understand what a saddle
point was
previous to reading this or do you know
what a saddle point is now
yes let us i'm just pulling up the um
paper in the window okay so people can
see it
um okay so
yeah the stability um okay
so it's the following sentence so we can
generalize the leop the function to a
global function that plays the role of a
potential function of any system
this follows by generalizing condition a
to allow for saddle points
so a saddle point is when the landscape
is shaped like a saddle
and there's like um
so if it were on top of a hill
the curvature is negative with respect
to all directions
right in a saddle point the curvature is
negative with respect to one of the
dimensions
but it's positive with respect to
another dimension
and so it's just like just like a saddle
yeah
okay
why do they call it that um and so
the ball on the top of the hill
is like an infinite multifurcator
like a little jiggle it could go any
direction
because it's unstable in every direction
saddle points
induce a symmetry
where that ball is never going to roll
up the hill
it's going to fall to one side of the
saddle or the other side of the saddle
and one of those could be like um
a certain attractor and the other one
could be like another elevation
basically
um
though i don't know the details of how
the saddle point is related to
some of this lyapunov stuff
okay
all right so following
so this is they're showing that the
leopardive is equivalent to a potential
function
in physics a potential function psi
can be constructed to describe the flow
of
or forces acting on
a particle through a potential energy
gradient
so the potential
energy function f is
del
psi
so here's just one way to state the big
idea of equations five through nine
which are not discussed here
so the idea is create a potential
function
and when you think of potential function
think it's like kinetic energy
based upon elevation
but it's not for gravity and elevation
it's like balls falling down tall
buildings
but for
not gravity
for something that's related to
dynamical conversions
so if you were like at the bottom of the
bowl you'd only have a little bit of
potential energy
the potential function would be low if
you were really far up the ball
wall you'd have a high potential
function you'd have a long way to fall
that
is going to be reflected by a balance of
forces
namely an attractor force
which is the combination of the lorenz
force and the potential energy-induced
force
and then there's the dissipative force
and that's the frictional force
due to dissipative random fluctuations
so
that's like the velcro ball on the
velcro bowl
the friction is so high
that it still is being kept on the side
or it's rolling down very slowly or
something like that
combining these definitions we can
express the total balance total force as
a balance of the forces defined above
resulting in
and so just like if it was two colliding
vectors and then we were gonna express
the outcome resultant as like the total
forces being applied on something
it's like that but it's not about the
physical forces in the gravity it's like
more about
these forces
abstractly and so equation 10 is
expressing this balance of forces
on
x using a gradient landscape so there's
that
del psi
and here's the combination of forces
being expressed as
del psi dean
so
they use the word tensor here and when i
was reading this i didn't
i didn't see it i mean okay so if we're
having a tug of war on a rope
it might appear to the outsider upside
outside observer that there's a balance
but really what i read into this and
maybe i'm wrong was that there's a
tension
between these two forces
between the attractive force and the
dissipative force am i
am i misinterpreting that
someone has a different answer would be
awesome to hear it a tensor is like a
generalization of a matrix it's like a
matrix through time
i don't think that
it is directly related to tensile or
tensegrity
okay that being said you're right that
there is
a tension between these forces or there
can be
and that they like tension
can reflect
like a compromised position like if you
have a rope with tension on it
then the ending of the rope is going to
be like some compromise between the
various forces
and so we're thinking about like the
and then we're expressing it as like
this matrix
through time
that's what makes it a tensor not the
fact that the forces are in tension or
um opposition with each other yeah okay
i hope that's accurate okay
um
and then they follow 16 again
and transform that expression in 10
into a more standard form using the
diffusion tensor gamma
and a tensor q
this is like a rewriting
that helps them get to this format
where f x is describing the flow of
states so that's the change in states
through time
and it's like a vector field
and it is going to be q minus gamma
so
tensor
minus diffusion
both of that so that multiplied by
that landscape
so that's kind of like the
decomposition
but if someone could explain this more
let's hear it
and my simple words this is where i i i
keep bringing up the idea that
maybe when we're looking at these things
through an active inference lens we're
not just looking through a frame
we're also looking through and they talk
about filters later on
so
so like
how do we how do we make sure that we're
including both
and that and sort of the tension between
both of those views working
together and being in tension with one
another so yeah
this is very this is very formal
but i think it kind of reinforces that
there's there's
what's inside the
the
the partitions and then what's going on
within them as well
yeah
and it um so it's describing the flow of
states resulting from this conservative
and dissipative forces so if q and gamma
were the same
then the flow would be zero
if one is larger than the other then
it's going to be dominated by that
component with respect to being
multiplied by this landscape
so
we'll return to it many times
okay
variational free energy um
what did you want to add on this slide
well i i don't know that there any i
mean most people already know what we're
talking about in terms of variation free
energy but what they what they're doing
is introducing it in terms of so now
where does the model
the model of a of a
biological entity
where is that sourced from and that's
this sort of idea of these
these
these things like
posterior beliefs the foundation or the
the idea that we we don't walk into a
situation completely blind we have some
sort of prior
and we're modeling situations where
internal states can be interpreted and
framed as a generative model so it's not
they're focusing on the model aspect of
this as opposed to the generative
processing side they're gonna they're
going to talk about what the external
milieu is and where the generative
process is here shortly
great so
good point to pause the video and read
this because we're not going to read it
out here but you're absolutely right
they're focusing on the generative model
of the agent of the cell
not
doing that
analysis on the niche for example
all right
section 2.2.1
okay so this is a fun part
we can describe dynamics in generalized
coordinates of motion denoted with a
tilde
where x tilde is defined as
x tilde equals x that's like the
absolute state of x and then x with a
dot is the first derivative of x that's
called velocity
x with two dots is um or a two double
prime depending on the notation is the
acceleration
what people don't always know is that
there are higher derivatives and they
also have names so the third derivative
is the jerk and then the fourth fifth
and sixth are the snap crackle and pop
so that's just kind of funny
but the generalized coordinates of
motion which came up in
number 26
have to do with doing
prediction on not just
um
how high or low something is or like on
the number line left and right that
would be like if x were just one number
but even if it's just one number that
we're tracking like body temperature for
example
we might be interested in kind of
unpacking that
into this generalized coordinate where
we want to know body temperature and how
fast it's changing
and how fast that is changing
and so one can imagine that once a zero
has been achieved
the higher derivatives are also zero if
it's zero through time the higher
derivatives are also zero
if it's zero instantaneously that's not
always the case
but if it's zero through time then it's
kind of like you've cashed out the
derivatives the derivative of zero just
stays at zero and so it's like if the
position is unchanging
the velocity is zero
ends
if the position is five miles an hour
going in the same direction the velocity
is constant but the acceleration is zero
so keep on carrying that out to how fast
things are changing how fast they change
et cetera et cetera
and then they're going to take that x
tilde
how x tilde changes with time x tilde
dot
equals
the flow on tilde
plus
a variance
so a noise or fluctuation a random
fluctuation term
this is the form of the langfine
equation
generalized coordinates of motion
plus
a random fluctuation term
um
any of the
mathematical colleagues would be awesome
to hear
how this is related to the weiner
assumptions
etc but we're going to continue
so
using the helmholtz decomposition we can
now express steady state flow in terms
of a divergence free component and a
curl free descent on a scalar of the
operative function l of x tilde
to obtain
f of x tilde
equals there's the q minus gamma that we
saw a few slides ago multiplied by now
the l
so here we had f of x
not generalized coordinates of motion
q minus gamma
del
psi of x that was the potential function
now because the potential function and
lyapunov are related to each other
we're looking at the generalized
coordinates of motion
using the same q minus gamma helmholtz
decomposition but multiplying it now by
the opening of exponents or i'm sorry
the lyapunov function on
x tilde
it's the solution at non-equilibrium
steady state and is exactly the same
solution
for
the flow of particles in the classical
treatment above
crucially we can now see the operative
function is the negative log probability
of finding the system in any generalized
state
the leopard of x tilde is the negative
natural log of
how surprised
one should be p of x tilde this is known
as self-information of a state in
information theory surprisal or surprise
in bayesian statistics it is the
negative log evidence so
the change in the generalized
coordinates of motion
f of x tilde
breathe
is an irrotational solenoidal
decomposition
that's the left part of the right hand
side
multiplied by a lyapunov function
which also has the interpretation of
surprisal
so if you are exactly
resting so to speak
you'd be totally unsurprised
in summary any weekly mixing dynamical
system at non-equilibrium steady state
will events give us evidence for or look
like it is
a flow that can be decomposed into a
gradient flow on surprise and an
accompanying solenoidal flow
because we can associate the lyapunov
function in 18 with a free energy
the system is effectively minimizing
a free energy in its convergence to a
set of attracting states
which have a high probability of being
occupied
so it's a little
circular it's like
we're finding ourselves where we expect
to find ourself
and so if we just said well how
surprised are we
and let's gradient descend towards not
being surprised
just at a first approximation
we would find ourselves
in regions of low surprise
and we would be surprised to find
ourselves in regions of high surprise
is it is it circular or is it kind of
the byproduct of a recursive
process
again i'm asking i'm not questioning
it's a great question
in like a really
meta way all of math is circular once
the axioms have been stated because like
the equal sign is there so we're just
you can add one to both sides and it
would still be equal so is that circular
right um it's useful
and that's what matters for this paper
okay yeah
um
we're not going to talk about it too
much but in a dot one we absolutely will
and that's this least action principles
in 2-2-2
and they even give the example we love
to see
for example in colonies ants find the
path of least action to harvest food and
bring it to the colony
citation needed slash let's see that
but conceptually
no problem
this example considers their paths as
flow channels or trajectories finding
the least average action for each
instance of foraging given available
resources
so
what does least action principle mean
what does least action mean
and what is it necessary or sufficient
for because certainly foraging is not
the least biochemical expenditure of
energy
that's like the sort of
naive interpretation of least action
meaning just stay where you are
but we're thinking about a usage of
least
action that impels this ant to forage in
an adaptive way
such that even when it's foraging trip
is hard and the seat is heavy and it
gets like lost or something
that is still a realization of at least
action on something it's still a ball
rolling down a hill as efficiently as it
can
in a space
so it's a
nuanced topic that
it will be great to discuss
because they also write minimization of
action in an open system leads to
structure formation
so that'd be a good thing to unpack okay
carrying on
in dissipative random dynamical systems
action is not minimized for each element
of the system
but on average over an ensemble of
elements or repeated trajectories of the
same element
since self-organizing open systems are
not conservative
their structured flow is
quintessentially dissipative
good to
think about that and hear many
perspectives and questions on it
classically for a conservative system
the lagrangian is defined as l
this is
l not the operative now it's lagrangian
equals t minus v
so t is the kinetic energy
of the particles and v is the potential
energy
[Music]
and so that's how
the
trajectory of system states could be
solved for a conservative system
where the total energy is going to be
conserved
but
they're
opening up into this
dissipative and open
scenario
where this is not going to cut it
um
[Music]
a little bit more detail on least action
which we're not going to go into
okay
continuing on
two two three markov blanket
okay
a robust literature is developing about
around the ability of cells and other a
neural non-neural systems measuring
aspects of their environment via
specific sensors
they introduce here the markov partition
as this general case of
separation of states into four
categories
e
external states
sensory states s
active states a internal states i
and so the little e is like it's a
realization of big e that's the bigger
space
and then
x tilde
comes back
and the generalized coordinates are
going to be
a realization of values of those
partitioned states
so we've talked about the markov blanket
before
but now we're interested in
the generalized
flow on
the blanket partition states
so
here's what the markov blanket looks
like
and
we'll talk more about it in the dot one
and dot two what do the arrows mean and
why are sense and action connected
what part of the cell are we looking at
is it a part of the cell is it a model
of a cell
all these things that have come up
before but just to say that's their
figure one and table one gives the math
formalisms
okay anything to add on markov before we
continue
no because we'll we'll unpack yeah
so
this is where they apply the markov
blanket
so m is describing the markov partition
that defines the underlying random
dynamical system such the cell
so that is like um
the uh
model that's the partition markov
partition of the cell
so inserting c into a and b is going to
give
there's
a is actions and i is internal states
so the top equation is basically saying
the flow
on action
is a function of sense action and
internal
and then
it has a right hand side so the flow on
action
the performance of action
is
and then there's that gamma minus q
but now they have a subscript a because
it's those about the action landscape
multiplied by del triangle on action
tilde generalized action
and then a self-surprisal
looking like
the self-surprise of
sense action and internal conditioned on
m partition
and the bottom equation in b 30 b is
basically the same
but it's the flow on internal states
f sub i on
generalized states of sense action and i
and that same gamma minus q
del self-surprise condition on model
so we're seeing some patterns come up
and even if um it's like confusing and
we all definitely are confused by it to
some extent we're starting to see like
some patterns
why does it matter to focus so much on a
and i the action
and the internal states because those
are like the ones we control
we know we don't control external states
directly
maybe we can intervene so that they
change differently but we know we don't
control them
we also don't directly control sense
states we're getting dealt this hand
every second by the niche the generative
process
and so we can
take action so that we can expect
different sensory outcomes but even then
we wouldn't be controlling sensory
outcomes
and so
a lot of active inference comes down to
doing inference on
internal model
internal states
generative model learning
and
action action selection
flows on action
um
[Music]
this
bounds the surprise
on the particular states which is the
internal and the blanket states
through
control of the autonomous states which
is just the action and internal states
the states we control
because of the sparsity
of the blanket
not every node is connected to every
node
there might be a factorized and
tractable form
to bound our surprise
about the particular states
in general it would be very difficult
problem to solve
however we can replace the lagrangian
that's the one
here
that was like going to be used for
conservative systems but it didn't
really apply
um
with a variational free energy
functional or of a probabilistic model
of how a system thinks it should behave
or how we think the system should think
it should behave
so it's hard to solve these
generally but
in practice there are heuristics such
that these are approximatable
section 2.4 goes like one layer deeper
into kl divergence in the vfe but we're
not going to go into it
okay
we're just going to keep on plowing
through
two three is bayesian filtering and
self-organization
we're not going to talk about it now but
the big questions here are like how does
bayesian statistics relate to identity
and what is self-evidencing
and there's probably a lot of other good
questions we could ask like why does
bayesian filtering and self-organization
come here
all right
modeling morphogenesis so now we
actually get to the contribution of the
paper
um which is the modeling of
morphogenesis so they're going to
illustrate self-organization to ness
using the variational principles above
by trying to explain the behavior of a
model of pattern regulation by
consideration of information processing
and error minimization with respect to a
specific target morphology in this
setting the game changes subtly but
profoundly
it's a dean line if i ever read one
um
above
which is what we've reviewed
the dynamics of any random dynamical
system equipped with a mark called
blanket can be formulated in terms of a
gradient flow on variational free energy
that was just
here the flow on action and the flow on
internal states
here we turn this formulation on its
head
by specifying a generative model
an implicit vfe function
and simulate self-organization by
solving the equations of motion in
equation 34.
so they're going to specify the form of
the attracting set
v
uh the generative model
and then they're going to let it ride
so
we have to just talk down
yeah
they specify the external dynamics as
the generative process
that's the niche
and the generative model
of that process which is being described
by the flow of internal states okay so
we're going to look at the figures
and then we're not going to even like go
into the details so let's just look at
the figures and see what they're doing
so
here's some empirical biology happening
in the lab of mike levin and others
so
in a
it turns out that when you dissect out
the center of a flatworm a planarian
those cells will remodel into a new worm
so cutting out the middle and it reforms
into this
new
flatworm and red is the head and then
like blue is the tail
so
there's a self-organization
of this target morphology even from an
initially clumpy cell
what they're going to do in b
is showing like the final fixed point
of these different cells so here we have
like four different cell types there's
like the red neural or head cells then
yellow cells green cells and blue cell
and then basically like this like three
two one one
um and then the bottom one it's this one
maybe they change the green and the blue
like i think these two should be green
and the bottom should be blue but
minor point but it's an attractor
on
this target morphology
um
and then
c
is describing a little bit about how it
happens which is that cells are
constantly comparing their sensed signal
concentration like of a gradient of some
um morphogen
to expectations by minimizing their free
energy functional
so it's like what kind of a cell type am
i
and what should i be expecting
flip side what should i be surprised by
because to say what i expect is
the other side of the coin of what one
is surprised by okay so they're modeling
this empirical scenario where a flatworm
can regenerate its form from just a
clump of cells here
and that
if we think about the location of these
cells as being like a steady state
attractor like we want to have this body
form last
then if all the cells just get in line
like that everything's going to work out
all right
how do we take this
first jump that we made from the
empirical biology
to the
state space framing
here it is an x y state space
and now take the next jump
one more mathematical
here on the right side
is
that
x y positioning of each cell
this is reflected by the position
in
x and y
of the cells so like negative nine and
zero so that's like this top red one
zero is the midline so it's like y and x
and here like negative five it's a
little lower
and then like negative four and four
it's like one is on they're on the same
y elevation
but then one is four to the left and one
is um four to the right
and so this e star of x
is the position
so it's um a matrix of position because
there's like
um eight cells
and two location variables per cell so
it's like a two by eight matrix
and it changes through time so it's a
tensor
the e star c
is the external signals
and so
in this
steady state attractor
all three red cells are getting like
signal one here's the binary signal
there are four signals but they only
have an on or off state in reality
there's many many more signals than four
and there's a lot more uh nuance than
just on or off but it's a
it's a toy example all three red cells
are getting the exact same signaling
milieu
of one one zero zero so factor a and b
are diffusing near me
but not c and d
the yellow cells are experiencing
those two diffuses and one other one
the blue cells are experiencing the
first the fourth and then the green one
is another
and so
this is like the attractor state
for a stable
location
and signaling expression
so converging to this spatially makes
your body look like that but the way
that you get a beach ready planarian
body like that
is actually by reducing your
your surprise on signal expression
okay so here's them
running it through time
so it's a time-lapse movie montage
of simulations of morphogenesis
and so here it is converging towards on
the right side
the morphology that's been discussed
here
and so the cells start out with
undifferentiated they know what they're
sensing
they don't know what kind of cell they
are
and they
don't know where they are
and then
they sharpen
their expectations about what kind of
cell they are
while also
moving into a different spatial niche
but they're not tracking their location
like i'm at three comma two where are
you
it's like this is what i'm biochemically
sensing
and so it's a relational morphology
that doesn't need the blueprint in the
nucleus
so it's a lot like an ant colony there's
not the nest architecture blueprint in
the brain there's the process for stigma
g
and then they show that with some other
um changes
in
the generative process
a positive squared gradient in the
generative process
they get double head formation
which some modulations have been shown
to empirically result in in the lab and
they can also make it so it gets double
tail formation
so it's just recapitulating this basic
example and then showing that like
modifying the external field changes the
morphology that gets attracted to
so those are the key pieces that's
modeling morphogenesis
as
bayesian inference
reducing surprise
with a variational free energy flow on
action and internal states action states
internal states
okay
um
we're not gonna go into it here
definitely for the dot one and dot two
so um 3.1 is the construction of the
model
they then
unpack that signal
matrix
the combination of the signals
and then um
[Music]
they give even more information about
modeling signals
and they also imbue it here with like
this steminess
which helps the cells start out with um
i believe a weaker prior
about what kind of cell they are which
translates to where they should be
um
in figure five
they do a targeted intervention in their
studying of anomalous cell behavior
and so basically they start off with
these um cells that have initially
unspecified state and they converge in a
this panels on a by 32 time points
they're converged to the target
morphology
but in b
they show that if one of the cells that
gets hit with a white arrow here
has a perturbed signaling response it
fails to correctly infer its place in
the ensemble
so b is like sort of like um it could be
like a genetic mutation or a targeted
modification of the signaling and it's
like that third red cell
never forms
and then in c
the same aberrant cell from b is
initially is rescued by an increased
signaling sensitivity of other cells
leading another cell
green arrow
to switch position with the aberrant
cell pink arrow
pretty
cool okay yeah i wanted to come up with
an analogy that would actually work that
would explain this like if
you're out geocaching one afternoon and
then all of a sudden
some
something was able to turn all the
lights off and then the person that was
geocaching beside you change their
behavior but i couldn't even come up
with a valid analogy to try to explain
this
how about um
uh we're playing american football
and so there's a plan and everyone's
trying to reduce their uncertainty about
how the plan is playing out from their
perspective
and so if all goes to plan we're all
going to deploy into the exact right
positions
but then
somebody um doesn't move
if each nestmate on the football team
has low sensitivity
then they're going to continue in their
own expected trajectory as if nothing
had happened that's kind of like what we
see in b it's like a partial rollout
whereas
this is changing the environment mixing
our metaphors etc
so that a high sensitivity
teammate
fills in for that critical position so
that the attractor state of the strategy
can still be morphologically realized
even though
um there still is that one individual
who's not moving
but but they're not interfering
with the strategy's attraction
but we'll come up with probably some
other and better ways to talk about it
okay
and then they um just mentioned that
this is something that can be modeled
and it's in spm
and also on franz kuchling's um
github
so maybe we will um look at the code
and then
just to say that we're not going to go
into it at all today but all of section
4 is super interesting
they review some of the mathematical
assumptions and limitations of the model
there's a really fascinating discussion
about variational principles and open
systems
and so um
[Music]
like just to read we have shown that the
variational free energy minimization in
active inference is related to the
variational principle of least action
it is worth pointing out with where
these two approaches
diverge
two instruments
in a wood diverged
and then it's all about that divergence
and the contrasting
and so
i think there's gonna be a lot of
unpacked there
and then they have some closing remarks
on the applicability in biological
systems and some of the predictive
capacities of the simulations
um in terms of like you could make a
simulation of a healthy functioning
tissue and then have predictive capacity
about asking counter factuals well what
if this happened what might i expect so
that is
a lot of info so
thanks to everybody who's been
watching and
again hope that especially with some of
these technical parts
that we were able to represent it with
high integrity
so you won't have the last word but what
would you say in closing as we move from
the dot zero into the one two and beyond
well first of all you went through a
heck of a lot of stuff in a very
short period of time so that's that's
quite the gradient flow right there so
that's impressive
um
i don't think much in terms of i mean
this is a classic example of where you
have to unpack
as opposed to
lots of the other papers that are maybe
more philosophically based whether you
you
provision like you pack a bunch of stuff
and then you kind of go off on a bit of
a journey and i think in the point one
and the point two we may still be doing
a little bit more unpacking just because
of the
the the density of this kind of
information but that doesn't i mean you
want to be able to do both so i think i
think being able to cover
this and
hopefully we got it right like i
i did my best to try to understand it
and i think he did a good job of
explaining it so we'll see who shows up
in the point one and two whether the
point one and two or more unpacking or
maybe
starting to actually
think of ways that we could employ this
you already mentioned that we could we
can apply it to digital teams but
whether or not people have the
confidence to be able to take this and
apply it like they've done to
morphogenesis
maybe that's part of that conversation
cool
yeah i'll be looking forward to
going through with multiple
concurrent regimes of attention
some of the formalisms that we either um
disgraced or skipped in this discussion
and then keeping it open
to think about
morphogenesis like
where has morphogenesis been in numbers
1 through 38
why haven't we been talking about
morphogenesis and if not morphogenesis
then what else have we been focusing on
um
[Music]
how does it relate to embodiment
and to spatial and physical aspects of
cognition
there's so many interesting angles
and uh
i'm sure we'll have a lot to discuss so
dean thanks a ton for all the help on
the slides and for this discussion
um
[Music]
hope to see you in the coming weeks
all right thanks daniel take care peace
see you later